-Rachel Dratch!
Oh, my gosh, pal.
-Let me fix myself here.
Hi! Pally!
-Thank you
for playing "Password."
-Oh, my God, that was, like,
the highlight of my year.
-Could you believe us?
-I love those kind of games.
-But could you believe --
-We really had
a psychic connection going on.
-That was unbelievable.
We almost didn't even
need to look at the cards.
-I know.
We were like -- Yeah.
I feel like that's years of
"SNL" together.
-I think it's what it is.
-I don't know.
-I can't even tell you how
psyched I am and happy for you.
You're nominated for
a Tony award, buddy.
I mean, come on!
-I know.
-Who does it better than you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Who does it better
than Rachel Dratch?
Come on. We --
-Thank you.
-We've known each other
for over 20 years.
-Oh, my God, so many years.
-Would you ever see us,
back then, where we are now?
-Well, you know what?
it's funny
'cause I was thinking
about this,
because you were always so good
at chatting up the host.
And we'd be waiting around
during rehearsals,
and you're standing there next
to some really famous person.
And you were always really good
at making them feel
comfortable and talking,
so I think it's perfect
that you're doing this now,
'cause it's your wheelhouse.
But I was always, like, so shy.
And I'd stand next to them
and just, like...
Like, we'd just
stand there in silence
and then I'd be like, "Do you
live in New York or L.A.?"
[ Laughter ]
And it was --
-That's your question?
-I made things so awkward.
-Yeah, like,
that was my go-to.
Then they'd say an answer,
and I'd be, "Hmm, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
I think this is
the perfect job for you.
-But are you more comfortable
now talking to celebrities?
-Um, maybe a little bit.
But I still -- Yeah, I still,
like, freak out when I...
Actually, like, we got to meet
so many of our comedy heroes.
So I'm more comfortable
with that.
But if I see, like, a rock star,
I get like -- really like,
"Oh, my God!"
So I --
I got to meet Elvis Costello
once at this event.
And I was like -- I totally
fanned out totally.
[ Muttering ]
[ Laughter ]
And then -- Yeah, those are
the people that I really --
Oh, and I got to meet
Debbie Harry
'cause we were doing
this thing together.
I was so excited.
-Blondie.
-Cool.
-And I went up to her --
Well, I didn't say anything
the whole time,
because I was just...
And then, at the very end,
I was like,
"Um, I just want to say
I'm a really big fan.
And "Parallel Lines" was
the first album I ever bought."
And she was like, "You bitch."
[ Laughter ]
Because -- But in fun, because,
like, I was -- I was aging her.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I see, yeah.
-"I was only 7."
Whatever.
-That's what you want to hear
from Debbie Harry.
It tracked with
her cool personality.
-You're nominated for a Tony.
I love the Tony Awards,
by the way.
That's one of my
favorite award shows
out of all the award shows,
Because I feel like,
for Tony Awards,
they're like, "Hey, you're
nominated for this musical.
Do it for us."
[ Laughter ]
You know? What?
No other award show does that.
-Right, right, right.
-"Go do it for us.
Let's see if it's good.
It's okay."
You know, it's like, "Wow."
-Yeah.
-But it is all performers,
all entertainers.
Do you think that "SNL"
prepared you for Broadway?
-Well, you know, the thing --
as you know,
the pressure of "SNL" is
you had to write something
every week.
Or try to write something.
So that was the thing
that was really hard
about "SNL."
And this is just, like,
you show up.
It's all written for you.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-You just have the fun part.
So it's a lot of fun.
This part that I have
in this play is like,
I'm kind of the clown of the --
Like, I get to do
a lot of physical stuff.
And it's really fun.
It's kind of "SNL" style.
My part is, anyway.
-Did your son --
Did Eli freak out
when he heard the news that
you're nominated for a Tony?
-So, I have an 11-year-old son,
and he did not know
what the Tonys were.
But then I told him,
and then he was excited.
-Okay, good.
-And then he went to school.
Then, he went to school,
and he was like,
"My mom's nominated for a Tony."
And they also did not know
what a Tony was.
[ Laughter ]
But also then, I did --
I was on the fence
about having him come
to the show,
'cause there's a lot of
adult language in this show.
And so I was, kind of like,
"Should I do it or not?"
And then all the "SNL" ladies,
I consulted them.
They said, "You got to
have him come to the show."
So he went to the opening night.
And, yeah, it was really fun.
He did learn a lot of new words.
[ Laughter ]
But then afterwards, it was cute
because afterwards, he didn't --
he's like, "I don't know why
you made such a big deal
about the words."
And then he was like,
"That was so funny!"
Like, I was glad I had him
come to the show, but...
-He laughed.
-Should I tell
that the next day, my mom
came to the show, too.
[ Laughter ]
The next day, was walking with
him and my mom down the street.
And he goes, "Well, now I know
another 'C' word,
besides [Bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-So you can bleep that out.
I don't know how he learned
the other word,
but he learned another "C" word.
-Doesn't matter.
-New York City is a
tough place to grow up.
-He's a New York kid.
[ Laughter ]
-This is your Broadway debut.
-Maybe we'll cut that out.
-No, yeah.
-So Child Protective Services
doesn't come calling.
-We can cut that out.
-Or maybe not. Okay.
What?
-This is your --
This is your Broadway debut.
-It is my Broadway debut, yes.
-And you get nominated.
How did you get involved
with this play?
-Okay, so, Susan Stroman.
-Legend.
-Five-time Tony winner? Yeah.
-She directed us,
and I had done a few readings
with her before.
So she called me up to do this.
-She knew you.
-This part was open, and
this part looked fun to me.
-I know you've done theater.
-Yeah, I've done
some off-Broadway stuff,
but this was the first Broadway.
-Did you dream of Broadway?
-Yeah, so, when I was little,
like, you know, I saw "Annie"
when I was whatever.
-Yeah.
-10 or something.
And then I was like,
"How did they get up there?"
This might've been like --
I don't know, did you have --
maybe not "Annie,"
but maybe you saw, like...
[ Laughter ]
-No, it was "Annie."
It was "Annie."
I'm like, "I should be Annie."
[ Laughter ]
"That's me."
♪ The sun will come out ♪
Danny.
Why can't there be "Danny"?
You know?
-But I don't sing like that.
So I was never like,
"I'm gonna be like that."
But...
[ Laughter ]
-♪ I'm gonna be a star ♪
-No.
[ Laughter ]
I just was like,
"How do they do that?
How does someone get in this?"
You know.
It was always kind of a dream.
Yeah.
-Can I read you some reviews?
And if you don't want
to hear them,
maybe plug your ears, 'cause
I'm gonna read them anyway.
-Then, yes, you can read them.
-"Rachel Dratch is
one of theater's certifiable
comic treasures.
Her comic timing is great.
Her line readings are giddy fun.
Her performances are
"roll over and die laughing,"
irresistibly funny."
From "Variety," about you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Awesome.
But I'm still happy.
"This is the role Rachel Dratch
was born for" --
"The Washington Post."
Yeah, that's not bad.
And then this is my --
"New York Post."
New York --Come on, that's --
you got to go to New York.
The "New York Post" says,
"The genius Rachel Dratch
is a riot.
Dratch doesn't have to work
for the laughs.
She gets them by existing."
Bang!
[ Cheers and applause ]
What in the world!
-Thank you for reading those.
Geez.
-Come on, buddy.
Can you tell everyone
what the play is about?
-I've heard it described
kind of as a cross between
"Noises Off" and "Veep."
It's a farce.
There's seven women in it.
It's, like, rollicking crazy.
We're trying --
So, you never see the president
in this.
He's not really a character,
but he --
-It's the woman
behind the president.
-The woman behind him,
so we're all trying
to, like, keep the White House
going or, you know,
put out all the fires
and all that stuff.
And then madness ensues.
-Yeah.
-And -- yeah.
-But the first half of the play,
you're pretty --
-The first half of the play,
I act kind of probably
how I did at "SNL."
Like, I mean, in my more --
-Shy?
-In my more shy -- Yeah.
So, like, in the first half
of the play,
I'm this, kind of, shy,
mousy secretary
who just, like, wants
to do right
and always saying she's sorry.
But then I accidentally
take this unnamed drug.
And then, the second half,
I am like, you know --
-Off the rails.
-Yeah, I'm off the rails,
claiming my power.
It's really fun.
Kind of, like, my id
gets to come out,
and I take a real journey.
-Ah, I love it, bud.
-Yeah, it's really fun.
-Well, of course,
we have to toast.
-Ooh.
-Because not often you're --
-Oh, my gosh.
-One of your best friends
are nominated for a Tony.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I love you so much.
-Thank you. I love you, too.
-You totally deserve this.
Rachel Dratch, everybody!
Here's to your Tony nomination!
You know I'm rooting for you,
buddy.
Rachel Dratch, "POTUS,"
is playing
now through August 14th
at the Shubert Theatre.